on va démarrer par le plus chiant et
gilles verdez comme ça ce sera fait
alors est ce que vous regrettez d'avoir
eu comme chroniqueur eric zemmour
j'arrête pour du crâne fois ça du temps
où eric zemmour était chez nous je
trouvais très bien d'ailleurs tout le
monde me trouvais très bien à cette
époque là c'est après qui sait que ça a
dégénéré
donc avec le recul je pourrais regretter
l'évolution qu'il a eues mais en tout
cas quand il était dans on n'est pas
couché pendant les six ans où sept ans
je crois cinq ans d'ailleurs peut-être
cinq ans franchement tout le monde
trouvait qu'il était très très bien et
quand il a dérapé c'était en dehors d'on
n'est pas couché salut les terriens ou
dans d'autres émissions en tant
qu'invité puis ça a dégénéré par la
suite ce que je regrette c'est ce qu'il
est devenu
parce qu'il était quand il était chez
moi alors c'est vrai que c'est un peu
nous l'aurons qui avait rêvé lyrique
zemmour aux yeux du grand public non il
était chez stéphane bern oui mais non
mais quand même si c'est important
il était parce que catherine barma l'a
repérée chez stéphane dans une émission
qui est passé sur canal tous les samedis
oui il était il a fait cette émission
avant la villa mais il était beaucoup
moins bon pour les gens c'est vous alors
oui bon ça fait vous avez mis en lumière
c'est ce que j'ai ce qu on est alors en
regard dont vous avez fait c'est vrai
que vous avez fait même émergé
énormément de ballons alors je pense pas
qu'on puisse dire eric zemmour c'est un
autre style mais c'est vrai que il vous
a rejoint pour lancement on n'est pas
couché en 2006 entend polémiste d'abord
accompagné de michel polac et ensuite en
duo avec celui qu'on connaît tous notre
ami eric naulleau cette période là c'est
vrai que c'est chou tous les samedis
soirs c'était vraiment aimer les gens
aimaient ça ah bah oui bah non mais moi
c'est assez haut
c'est vrai que c'était une période
c'était incroyable ils sont passés tous
les samedis soirs c'était on attendait
avec impatience regarder faut qu'on
vient de mettre un petit peu d'esprit la
baisse et ouais c'est vrai qu'au new
c'est vrai que nous on n'est pas comme
lui on n'est pas des professionnels de
la bonne humeur pour enfant de quatre
ans alors évidemment c'est typique
[Applaudissements]
malgré la guerre depuis qu'on est petit
ce qui est déjà une chance dans la vie
d'avoir une passion
absolument voilà moi c'était le football
pour moi aussi j'ai aussi moi je les
pratiques et moi aussi
il songe à se passe en ville
les chiffres officiels sont faux
j'ai ici j'ai mis six zones minées par
les niveaux sous les bâches
[Applaudissements]
alors je vois que vous regardez c'était
vous preniez beaucoup de plaisir des
souvenirs incroyables
c'est une époque qui quand même à
marquer les samedis soir parce qu'à
cette époque-là n'y avait pas beaucoup
d'autres émissions de ce genre là après
les débats se sont démultipliés sur
toutes les chaînes donc tout c'est
devenu comme axe est vrai que le dio le
premier duo faudra clé c'était michel
polac eric zemmour est ensuite eric
naulleau et avec le zemmour mais voilà
pour moi c'est de l'histoire tellement
ancienne que ça fait alors maintenant
huit ans que je travaille plus avec erik
guay en avril bien en parler bon voilà
en avril dernier les tirs venus sur
votre relation elle expliqué qu' qu'il
vous trouvez secte et regardent vous
accepté tout de suite lorsque laurent
ruquier vous propose vous appelle oui
oui ça j'ai accepté très vite je sentais
entre ruquier barma à l'époque cela près
ça a changé
une grande une grande liberté une grande
de voiliers ils étaient ouverts ils
étaient pas il n'était pas devenu
sectaire ils le sont devenus après mes
pas me trouver
ah oui je veux dire j'ai pas du tout
apprécié
ce qui ce qu'il m'a fait pour la sortie
de mon dernier livre où il m'avait
promis de m'inviter et où il a n'a pas
tenu sa parole
je vous trouve ça assez médiocres de sa
part de l'ingratitude humaine fait
partie de mon logiciel je le sais mais
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui j'ai pas trop
envie de l'inviter tout d'abord il a
suffisamment d espace
à l'époque il en avait pas aujourd'hui
l'euro n'avait pas eu à en rajouter
d'accord mais très bien voilà c'est vrai
c'est vrai qu'on dit que oui juste une
chose je vous dit ce qu'il est devenu
voilà oui il est devenu quoi zemmour
plus extrêmes ils l'étaient ses succès
aussi et puis s'est laissé emporter par
ses idées
ou alors peut-être qu'ils les avaient
déjà et qu'il les maîtrisait mieux ah
parce qu'on connaît pas les gens mais
moi j'ai toujours c'est la fameuse
phrase du moment sur toutes les
polémiques il faut distinguer l'homme
l'homme avec qui j'ai travaillé pendant
ces années là était quelqu'un que
j'appréciais beaucoup c'est quelqu'un
qui est très agréable à travailler très
aimable mais c'est vrai je partageais
déjà passé idée de son ça se voyait
pendant les émissions
c'était le but il y avait à quelqu'un de
très à gauche michel polac monsieur ries
quelqu'un de très à droite eric zemmour
sauf qu'après il est devenu très très
très très très très très très près à y
aller sinon refaire la tendresse et la
vérité c'est qui le meilleur conducteur
que vous ayez une on n'est pas couché
alors pour moi j'ai beaucoup d'affection
pour michel polac parce que bien sûr
d'abord il a fait pour moi le succès de
l'émission c'était une saison c'était un
homme qui faisait qu'on a on s'est dit
tiens il va se passer quelque chose le
samedi soir parce que il avait encore
quand même l'image de droit de réponse
et et c'est vrai voilà même ça n'a été
qu'un an ça a été l'année qui a lancé
l'émission avec florence foresti aussi
et le moins celui qui vous allemand
alors le moi j'irai parmi les derniers
chroniqueur parce que tous ceux qui ont
été pendant plusieurs années dans
l'émission franchement c'est que si je
les ai choisis avec le hamas et que je
les appréciais je vais plutôt prendre
parmi ceux qui étaient en doublettes
j'ai pas trop aimé le dessinateur jul
que j'apprécie pour son talent de
dessinateur marc roche qu'on l'a choisi
pour devenir chronique et il a fait que
de la promo pendant deux heures pour
cent pour son album de bande dessinée
j'étais pas le propos le propos donc où
j'avais eu le même problème avec bernard
mentir le départ
vidéo et ses chats sais c'est que parler
de son album c'est vraiment intéressant
rené malleville question au volant à
[Rires]
l'horaire au destin alors voilà vous
devez nil souvent votre avis sur le
gouvernement le cna
mais est ce que vous aimez le professeur
how about me fait plutôt marrant moi
j'aime bien les gens qui me fait marrer
[Rires]
j'aime bien les gens qui donnent des
coups de pied donc il est content tu as
bien professeur à ou choisir entre la
lente et d'extraits si je préfère de
loin c'est bien alors on a une autre
question question de bernard montiel
alors vous allez voter mélenchon je
crois en 2010 est exact est-ce que les
mêmes cinq ans avant et est ce que vous
le regrettez j'ai voter mélenchon au
premier tour n'était pas au deuxième et
bien sûr les maquereaux au deuxième tour
mais non je ne le regrette pas parce
qu'au premier tour c'était encore
quelqu'un de présidentiable j'ai été un
peu déçu ensuite par son attitude
hostile où il le sait mélenchon et lenny
dix fois mais oui j'ai été déçu le soir
du deuxième tour j'ai pas apprécié le
fait qu' il soit pas plus à mon sens
plus républicain mais bon je pense qu'il
va se représidentialiser pour la
prochaine présidentielle
c'est qui votre pire invitez votre
meilleur invités de toutes les émissions
c'est compliqué on a eu plein d inviter
les bons invités c'est ce moi je trouve
toujours au qu'on connaît pas bien par
exemple quand j'ai reçu et monica
bellucci jeu c'était la première fois
que la rencontre est que je
l'interviewais et je sais qui a été à
peu terrorisée à l'idée de venir dans
l'émission et puis ça s'est super bien
passé elle venait pour un un film de
kusturica et boire plus j'avais pas
forcément une image très favorable
et quand j'ai bossé sur son dossier je
me suis aperçu du nombre de films c'est
parfois c'est intéressant de s'arrêter à
un moment sur la carrière de quelqu'un
et je me suis dit mais non c'est une
vraie actrice elle a fait est là il
bref filmographie de ce que je suis
arrivé sur le le plateau en ayant changé
d'avis sur elle alors elle a été
adorable ça s'est super bien passé et je
crois qu'on va se marier l'année
prochaine je peux venir je peux venir en
aide une question de kanye et oui on a
reçu il ya deux trois semaines jean
pierre pernaut qui nous a dit que je
pouvais pas vous plairait de la question
voir parce que vous pensez de lui et si
à quelqu'un que vous ne pouvez pas
blairer aussi dans le milieu non moi je
n'ai jamais il ya quelqu'un dont je dis
je peux pas le blairer parce qu'il est
par exemple jean pierre bouretz jean
pierre pernaut serait pas de rennes
j'aime plutôt bien jean-pierre non pas
parce que vous le cheminot journée en
revanche que j'aimais pas les sujets qui
traitait mais ça c'est une question de
goût mangoua moi c'est pas forcément le
goût est d'ailleurs la preuve c'est que
tu faisais à kars que ce qu'il avait
fait un carton euros au trésor et est
très bien il ya des gens qui aiment le
journal de 13 heures de pernaut qui
aimait ça tant mieux pour eux et tant
mieux pour jean-pierre mais j'ai rien
contre jean pierre pernaut moi je
n'aimais pas les sujets abordés dans son
jeu et ça ne m'intéressait pas je
préfère un peu plus de politique
étrangère donc je préférais le journal
de france 2 mois mais c'est une question
goût ça c'est tout est en bois en
revanche contrairement à lui je ne me
serais jamais permis de dire je ne peux
pas le blairer c'est pas sympa vraiment
pas ce qu'il a dit il connaît pas on
connaît pas une connaît pas il sait ça
va me dit samuel hadida alors les plus
connus
il a thani qu'on adore il a dit non mais
il a dû parier je les ai reçus tous les
deux corps sont cette fois les arbres
pareil lieu goethe est ingrat comme le
disait mon mais je crois pas je pense
que tous les gens qui me connaissent
dans ce métier je crois est inverse de
la gratitude et lui pour le coup il est
ingrat parce que quand il a fait de la
promo pour sa pièce de théâtre je les ai
reçus très amicalement et très gentiment
à plusieurs reprises aux grosses têtes
lui et sa compagne dont je vois pas
pourquoi c'est bien à balancer ça m'a
peut-être parce que j'ai pas les mêmes
idées politiques que lui ça c'est
certain
c'est ça qu'ils dérangent et
d'intolérance de sa part mais pas de la
mienne s'était pas jean michel willot
avaient fait une remarque malicieuse sur
les candidats gays tout à l'heure de
l'amour est dans le pré qui sont très
beaux j'avoue voilà donc jouer savoir
puisque vous avez fait votre coming out
dans les médias il ya quelques temps
pourquoi ça a été un poids médias moi je
les fais sur scène il ya très longtemps
dans les années 80 après dans les médias
ça a été un peu officialisé enfin pour
ceux qui n'ont pas suivi le théâtre en
tout cas pourquoi ça va c'était
important pour vous de l'avoir fait et
comment vous l'avez vécue parce que je
me sentais mieux dans mes bottes après
l'avoir dit dans les années 90 c'est
vrai que c'était plutôt gonflé à
l'époque passé courage on n'était pas
nombreux à y faire et voilà mais en même
temps j'ai jamais on lui reproche
d'ailleurs la communauté game leurs
proches parfois j'ai jamais été
communautariste militants peut-être à
tort d'ailleurs parce que c'est vrai on
me le dit souvent mais alors c'est trop
facile vous profitez des avantages que
les militants c'est la discussion que
j'ai eue avec alice coffin j'ai trouvé
très intéressante de cette discussion
samedi dernier mais voilà j'en fais pas
un étendard mais je ne veux pas non plus
caché je cache ma vie privée en général
de toute façon mais je serai hétéro ce
serait exactement la même chose
hétéro homo pour moi c'est la même chose
maintenant je venais pas mentir sur qui
j'étais sultan c'est normal c'est bien
alors laurent on doit les questions de 8
heures on va voir la dernière question
serait une question twitter pour ce soir
pour laurent question twitter merci en
régie apparemment voilà c'est
l'interview vérité
est ce que c'est possible car jouant au
foot sur m6 tous c'est un peu la
question tout le monde ce pauvre non
écoutez franchement je serais surpris le
premier parce que on me dit mon jamais
rien proposé oui le non non ça c'est une
légende qui perdure d'année en année
parce que m6 a racheté voilà rtn mais
vraiment je vous jure qu'à aucun moment
ni thomas valentin nicolas de tavernost
merci le monde thomas valentin simon il
monte à vernon personne ne m'a jamais
rien proposé on s'est rencontrés on
s'est rencontrés ce qui est le pardon à
notre regard des dernières questions
elle nous fait un très bon match à bâle
abbas et nicolas ont plus que je connais
un twittos où l'on brasse nicolas
malaboeuf bas c'est un connard j'ai dit
ce que je pensais nord contre dix
c'était un animateur qui marque ses
émissions et que pardon pour les
chroniqueurs qui sont ici mais
l'émission c'est cyril hanouna
mais c'est vrai que c'est pour moi vous
êtes un bon animateur et un bon
fantaisistes j'appelle ça comme ça parce
que et c'est un couple qui bonhomme je
prends bien voila voila merci non